madam deputy speaker
employment is up
investment
is growing public services are improving
the public finances are stabilizing and
wages are rising
[Applause]
today's budget delivers a stronger
economy for the british people stronger
growth with the uk recovering faster
than our major competitors stronger
public finances with our debt under
control stronger employment with fewer
people out of work and more people in
work
growth
up
jobs up and debt down let there be no
doubt our plan is working
madam deputy speaker
this budget is about what this
government is about investment in a more
innovative high-skilled economy because
that is the only sustainable path to
individual prosperity
world-class public services because
these are the common goods from which we
all benefit backing business because our
future cannot be built by government
alone but must come from the imagination
and drive of our entrepreneurs
help for working families with the cost
of living because we will always give
people the support they need and the
tools to build a better life for
themselves
and
leveling up
because for too long
far too long the location of your birth
has determined too much of your future
because the awesome power of opportunity
shouldn't be available only to a wealthy
few but be the birthright of every child
in an independent and prosperous united
kingdom
madam deputy speaker
today's budget does not draw a line
under covid we have challenging months
ahead and let me encourage everyone
eligible to get their booster jabs as
soon as possible
but today's budget does begin the work
of preparing for a new economy postcovid
the prime minister's economy of higher
wages higher skills and rising
productivity of strong public services
vibrant communities and safer streets an
economy fit for a new age of optimism
where the only limit to our potential is
the effort we are prepared to put in and
the sacrifices we are prepared to make
that is the stronger economy of the
future and this budget is the foundation